[Music]
the world is a less safe place today
than it was the day joe biden took
office that's because biden is
non-transparent
is blatantly dishonest and is literally
dangerous
biden prioritizes afghans with no
connection to the united states and no
vetting over american citizens
in fact 100 afghan evacuees are being
investigated for possible ties to
terrorism
the world watches as biden according to
reports flies afghan men with child
brides pedophilia or human trafficking
where i come from into states like
wisconsin
over christians and young female soccer
players who are abandoned stranded and
left as hostages
joe biden has literally given a
terrorist organization their own nation
not only that we arm them to accomplish
their mission
as he tries to sell us lie after lie the
american people are seeing right through
it
in fact 51 percent aren't buying it his
approval rating continues to go down
right now 43 percent is the lowest in
his presidency and 60 disapprove of his
handling of afghanistan
you see joe we're smarter than you and
your minions think we are
you've been lying for months about
afghanistan about your exit non-strategy
about your non-decisions about what your
military chiefs have told you or not
told you it's all lies and dangerous
ones at that
you are no longer the commander-in-chief
you are the liar-in-chief
you spew lies as truth and then turn and
bobble away incapable of answering
questions
instead you send out your puppets on a
string to take fake umbrage and double
down on your lies
joe your behavior is not only a
dereliction of duty and your sworn oath
to protect and defend the constitution
and the people of the united states you
have aided and abetted the enemy that we
fought for 20 years with american blood
and treasure
while you try to restrict our second
amendment gun rights in the homeland you
leave the enemy with billions of dollars
of the most sophisticated military
equipment in the world
you vacated bagram air base a secure
facility from which americans and our
allies could be evacuated and instead
allowed the taliban to release their
so-called enemies isis k
causing our military to be sitting ducks
for an attack at the kabul airport
and 13 service members to be ultimately
returned home in caskets because you had
the enemy controlling what little
perimeter there was and your cold
unconcerned boredom as you repeatedly
look at your watch as those caskets were
placed on the tarmac was a disgusting
display of your animus and your
inability to feel for anyone but
yourself
and you talked about yourself to shocked
and grieved parents
and you have the gall to actually call
the exit an extraordinary success
as we close 20 years of war and strife
and pain and sacrifice
it's time to look at the future
not the past the extraordinary success
of this mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
liar for the 18 months before your
chaotic incoherent entrance onto the
world stage not one american was touched
not one american harmed or threatened in
any way because they knew donald trump
would respond
for 18 months not one american soldier
was killed not one 18 months and that
was because of the agreement we had a
very strong agreement it was conditions
based now there were many other parts of
the agreement also and if they violated
them you know that we went in and bombed
the hell out of them
joe you can't shine donald trump's shoes
he was and is a leader and showed us the
meaning of peace through strength
you caused chaos through incompetence
you didn't have the spine the brains or
the capacity to know what you were doing
joe i think it's time for you to go back
to the basement where jill can walk you
around and tell you where you are and
what to do you botch everything you
should be ashamed of yourself
you're not only a liar since this was
the biggest disaster in american
military history you are a weak feckless
individual whose catastrophic betrayal
of america and american families demand
impeachment resignation and a court
martial
and here's another lie
we'll not conduct a hasty rush to the
exit
we'll do it we'll do it responsibly
deliberately and safely there is a home
for you in the united states
if you so choose and we will stand with
you just as you stood with us if there's
american citizens left we're going to
stay to get them all out any american
who wants to come home we will get you
home
liar
how dare you put americans in the hands
of taliban and isis how dare you allow
empty planes to fly back to america how
dare you not have the military search
for americans like other countries did
for their people how dare you have your
state department threaten private
organizations and a network of veterans
of real americans who are trying to
return americans in our afghan allies
home i just learned multiple attempts to
state department and the department of
defense have basically been brushed off
they are not interested in our lists of
u.s citizens who are trying to get in
they were not interested in our list of
u.s green card holders so they were
behind the eight ball the entire time
you know when i hear from anthony
blinken and
jake sullivan
they tend they tend to repeat the lies
of the administration more than most
and i think the state department
has a lot to answer for on this we
haven't had any contact with them since
and i believe it's because they were
caught up in that um and and so what
they did by playing politics on this for
whatever reason so you don't know who
shuts you down from landing i don't know
what what i don't know who shut us down
but i think it was 100 directed from the
state department
joe are you really an american i don't
know of any leader from local town
council and up who would leave americans
behind and bring in unvetted afghans
with child brides in violation of our
laws
are you delusional
in your head you actually expected the
world to applaud you for ending the
longest war in american history you were
teed off because you thought that
september 11th would be about you
and parcho you're right
because going forward any assault on any
american the in the homeland or around
the world will be due to you and your
ineptitude
and that's my open let me know what you
think on my facebook and twitter hashtag
judge jeanine
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else